on this episode we find out how
competitive Kyle really is everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
the askgaryvee show episode 288 and I
have a tremendous guest a name that you
know even people that aren't fans of
NASCAR I think will know just because I
think the general awareness of Kyle
overall in culture is quite high and so
I'm excited to have him here get a sense
a little bit of his origin story I like
comic books in my life so kind of comic
book episode one is always kind of
interesting the first copy is the origin
stories those things get me excited
we'll go into that we'll go a little bit
into the current state of NASCAR from
his perspective and the drivers and the
influencer world and the social media
stuff and then we will take your calls
so if you are on Facebook right now
please start putting in your phone
numbers Andy is here he will select them
give us a sense of the kind of question
you want or where you're from feel free
to ask Kyle or I a a question of any
interest even if it's not the matically
to what we are talking about right now
but now we get to introduce the guest
Kyle thank you first of all sir good to
meet you so why don't you tell the
vaynernation there's a lot of people on
here who know you a lot of who don't a
little bit about yourself absolutely
well I'm the driver of the number 18
Eminem's Toyota Camry and the NASCAR
Monster Energy Cup Series race every
Sunday pretty much we don't have a whole
lot off weekends we run 38 times out of
the year now leading the point standings
currently and have been for I don't know
the last few weeks we've been pretty
successful we just won last weekend
actually in the Poconos and that was
pretty cool onto the book it was twice
actually my father-in-law was the
marketing lead for Gillette okay and
when he did the young guns thing I was a
part of the young guns
where we actually shook hands before
blue okay you were a young whip I'll
give you the year
I guess that's 2004 five maybe that
range so I was later I was a younger I
was later I was a later young gun so I
wasn't until 2009 actually I think that
might still fall into the time actually
right we got actually I so nonetheless
so I've been to the Poconos which which
is very kind of uh it's got a really
nice niche to it a compared to other
tracks it does I understand yeah it's
got its own understanding it's kind of
more of like the Churchill Downs like
old school like horse track racing type
thing and it's kind of where they've
kind of kept it I mean you had huge
success there uh last two years I want
to race there last year I want to race
there this year and then we're your
first two wins up there yeah yeah and
now you're feeling it I think I'm
feeling it I think I got it that's right
it's been a while getting to that point
number 18 currently leading the
standings how do you like um you know
I'm not a deep knowledgeable NASCAR fan
but I'll put it on at times I like to
know everything that's going on life and
I know there was a big scoring change in
the last couple years how do you how do
you personally you know I mean just as a
human forget about even your official
answer that probably has to support the
sport like just as a guy like the NASCAR
I'm just looking at them because I'm
just trying to figure out their reaction
to me saying this is off the record it's
super on the record you know how do you
like it did you like the scoring style
before do you like this one better so I
like this one better buzz so years ago
NASCAR his educated Seth for from the
60s 70s 80s 90s all the way to 2004 it
was all about whoever accumulated the
most points throughout the entire season
was your champion more like the English
Premier League football and Europe were
like there was no playoffs right correct
so when somebody really broke out in a
big time year that last two or three or
four rings done we're done yeah the race
their champion would be crowned two
races before the end of the year
the earliest ever do you know who uh I
would say anybody in this room have a
good set like that that Gordon win like
with five races to go than anybody petty
like when what seven eggs any buddy have
the ride would guarantee you those that
exist yes I don't know for sure
ninety eight yeah how many ways left
well he won 13 races in 1998 and
probably won the championship at least
or secured it with like four races left
to go of course yeah and and the way the
tour goes are the same places in order
did those last four like tracks always
get hosed or the last two tracks tend to
have the ability to get hosed or they
might have thought also on the flip side
have the biggest race of the year if the
way this season played out exactly so
it's kind of changed the schedule the
schedule always opens with Daytona yep
in the beginning of the year and it
always ends with Homestead in the end of
the year right now currently yes but
anywhere in between those points the
races have changed through the course of
me being in the sport now for the last
14 years and I see I see so the points
used to be all the way throughout the
year right then they started doing
points where you'd have like these
playoff points where they would reset
ten guys ten guys would make the
playoffs and those guys would start back
at zero and the last ten races were
really what mattered for those guys and
they would race for a championship in
those ten well if you had one or two bad
races in those ten you've pretty much
almost eliminated yourself and the
teammates because I know you guys are in
teams the teammates it must have gotten
very strategic in those last ten where
other teammates were like doing things
to other racers sometimes thank you
eligible of course a championship what
about win the championship I never saw
those moments really but in those last
ten races everyone's racing everyone is
still racing but if I was your teammate
even if like like as just a human if I
was really your teammate and you're the
lead dog and you're going for it and I
know like Dale Junior's like kind of in
it with you kind of sorta you're gonna
run him harder right I mean I you know I
don't want to like get politically
incorrect but I would like surely like
him to not have a good race so you just
run him harder I mean I wouldn't say
you're gonna deliberately crash the guy
right yes I would race him harder and my
if I was completely out of it which I
was cuz I'm not one of those 10 guys
that I was like 13th just for my own
kind of a competitive nature note my
sister was born to 13 so I do like 13 uh
but fives my number my whole life I
would definitely do that yeah sure even
though Chur owner even if you were like
Gil bro like that's not the [ __ ]
rules of the sport I'd be like cool and
be like [ __ ] that I'm still gonna do it
yeah like you know that's it okay so
that's how it was now now it is
of a mix of those together so now you
have the whole regular season we can
build up what's called like bonus points
playoff points and so the more success
you have you win a race you get five
playoff points towards your postseason
points so when you start the postseason
you've got these points built up of how
you're successful in the beginning is
ten would tend to go still ten races
would tend to go when we go to that
first tenth or that tenth race to go you
might have like 29 points or right now I
have 35 and there's gonna be guys that
are in the playoffs that's zero zero
right so I already have a 35 Oh John I
like that right so I'd like that that's
a nice solid minute so what they do then
is you're still accumulating those bonus
points through the final ten so you can
keep adding to that total
yep the guys that are down there at zero
could get five could be again whatever
they could get on a hot streak and get
closer yeah and there's a reset every
three okay you guys had a throw that was
Cruz you are good so much [ __ ] sense
of a good job NASCAR yeah here comes
this horseshit of this what is this it's
a race set every three races but threes
that like why don't you make the final
this is a war so what you just had races
so you have 16 guys in right yes
are there eliminations okay I can't even
remember if there's elimination so
you're not only you're not on the mic oh
my god I got it so guys it goes from 16
guys yeah the first three races and then
we're gonna eliminate four oh my god
okay right then you go the next three
races you eliminate another record like
it okay and you go the next three races
you eliminate another four so there's a
final four there's in the final fourth
or we've got one race with one rate
right nine oh right yeah yeah and maybe
a chance or maybe somebody's locked it
up based on these bonus points it takes
that nature or if you crash out and out
race somebody can like so that final
race gets really hot yes the final race
is all about the four guys that made it
to the final race that are gonna race
for a championship but they have AK
accumulated points like could you like
the last race is all 0 its whoever beat
to you points matter so wait until
matter so wait a minute you guys have
gone completely to a American sport last
NFL Super Bowl last game matters
the NFL yeah right because even NBA
baseball hockey the other me they all
have Game seven right right
and we're in the NFL business one and
done so wait so what you're what I'm
hearing
which sounds right which it sounds like
which I honestly I'll be very honest as
a casual as a hardcore sports fan of
football and basketball big boxing other
things this and that all of a sudden I
think this is a good idea I actually now
because of the education of this have a
far more likelihood of watching that
last race yeah because it's a one it's
like what it's like the reason you don't
get into sitcoms it's why binge watching
is working with Netflix like back in the
day when they didn't have that if you
missed the first eight episodes of
Wonder Years you're like do I really
want to get into it right now now you
could be behind the eight-ball for the
entire season and then go to the last
race and go okay these four guys got it
whoever's gonna beat whoever got it okay
done got one more time this is where
this one thing freaks me out though
which i think is fascinating actually
that final race isn't just the four of
you racing against each other correct
that's some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] okay I'll
say it again
forget about even teams you and I grew
up in the same town go karts and all
that [ __ ] that you guys do like that on
the way up yeah you're just my homie we
could be homies and we could be haters
I'm here enough but let's just say let's
see we're our real friends like I
[ __ ] best friends our first Born's
have each other's first name as the
middle name we are homies okay got it
I'm in this race I'm out of it this year
I clearly know which three guys you're
racing against it's inconceivable to me
that I'm not in that race thinking about
what nuances without crashing obviously
but what other thing could I do to
impact you winning this championship and
I'm not saying this is by the way for
everybody listen that's not a bad thing
I love things that are complex that is
really complex that is very complex yeah
so last year I got into a little mix-up
with a guy at in Las Vegas the third
race of the year right and it comes all
the way down to homestead I'm in the
Final Four I have a chance for the
championship there's the guy leading the
race there's this guy that I had an AR
myth and then I'm running third it took
me 12 laps to pass the guy to get into
second place to go run the guy down that
was leading the race that was leading
the championship that I'm racing for the
championship you must win this race
unless in the championship and and I
couldn't get there in time because I
wasted so much time passing the other
numbskull I love it I hear you no listen
I'll tell you why I love it I love it
because I'm thinking if I grew up in a
different family and different
circumstance and grew up with this sport
the way I did with different sport or to
be very frank I think listen this is my
whole thesis on NASCAR baseball and
everything else and you hold are you 33
great so you're you grew up in a as a
child in a golden era of NASA absolutely
on the Sun ups yeah you know I was such
a hardcore 42 I was such an early user
of ESPN I'm talking like 1984 when it
was like like you know bull riding and
like not with the ESPN that we grew up
with yeah I by accident consumed a lot
of NASCAR because they did a lot of
Nazca which was the reason it grew right
like I knew who Bill Elliott was right
like well he was the sports most popular
driver so you should 16 years in a row
yeah so like but but you have that are
sin I grew up in Jersey where like
NASCAR listen um in the 80s and 90s like
when you said NASCAR bevor like what
yeah so like you know so nonetheless I
think that what I just heard is exciting
because it's the you know clearly you
articulated super well and I think that
storytelling the reason people watch the
WWE is the story they want to know what
happens next right of course it's it's
it's a male soap opera
the reason Sports is so amazing to fair
that's the the the the recent sports are
so amazing is it's real-life drama
yes in the mind live it's live action
right uh and uh you being such a great
all-time driver you fall into the class
for sure that people either really love
you or they hate you because they love
somebody else that you is challenge you
as a top-five racer so for me I'm just
sitting now thinking if I hate you and
door when door I want one of the other
three guys to win that race I'm enjoying
the living [ __ ] out of those 12 laps
watching that drama and because I'm a
hardcore fan
I know exactly why it's happening me
johnny-come-lately who's gonna watch now
this year clearly I'm not gonna enjoy it
as much cuz I don't know the drama now
the announcers may do a good job and
fill me back in yeah and the beauty of
2018 I may go to goo you know you two
been trying to see the clip real quite
exactly like oh [ __ ] they really hate
each other's is awesome so that's cool I
like that it's all the time no listen
I'm too busy well actually know what the
Sunday thing weren't talking to you well
I know you're talking to the masses
wanting me over and if you win me over I
think I can bring more than one person
up see he is he's like the like just
looking at him like he's totally NASCAR
mutt he's a white dude exactly yes like
the whitest white guy in the room almost
which exactly my point just a hair too
north right where's the mason-dixon line
is it like the North Carolina Virginia
line is that the line where's
mason-dixon
all right well you're right I personally
take it so different who do you love
growing up Jeff Gordon was my guy period
well I like the sport as a whole like I
liked all drivers your parents were into
it
my dad was into it he wasn't he was a
big he was a big he was a really really
good racecar driver in Las Vegas where I
grew up that's Riley born and raised I
knew that right
he won races he won championships he was
a really really good amateur racecar
driver
he never made it professionally never
got a break never got found there wasn't
this hole so I get a media presence
right so I always just kind of followed
in my brother followed in his footsteps
first and then I kind of followed in
after that as well and the whole
family's been into racing so when we
were always watching races on Sunday
sitting down whatever I was a fan of the
sport I just enjoyed it but when I
really adore the other sport yeah yeah
I'm fan of all sports but like what's
your second favorite sport football and
then baseball and who do you like the
Denver Broncos and that's are you gonna
do an so you're in a real interesting
pickle okay well you're a Las Vegas born
Denver Broncos fan and the Raiders are
moving to Vegas you've got a weird
[ __ ] situation you're not the first
guy to tell me this so
going through your mind I'm a Broncos
guy respect I'm going to the rebound of
the hometown to see some Broncos these
loved you up into this point a really
nice guy I've got a little bit mad now
but I'm hoping you're a hair young but I
don't think you are you easily remember
the 98 AFC Championship game against the
Jets when you were losing ten nothing
cuz you were like what that was 98 what
are we in now to that out of it you're
13 yeah do you remember that game number
that gets you don't fully remember it I
don't remember that game yeah yeah so so
you so you grew up you're into it and do
you feel because your dad was a really
really good driver and your brother was
really in the sport as what was he
solidly good to he's yeah he races on
the cup to her with me well [ __ ] so he's
very good like I always am fascinated by
the youngest of that lineage I always
like I think there's a high percentage
of people at the professional sports
level that have had the luxury of dad
older brother just because of the DNA
the evolution and just a competitive
nature of when you're lucky enough and
this you know obviously with racing you
can understand it better than I do the
one-on-one nature but like it's
fascinating when you have an older
brother or sister for that matter in all
sports actually sister brother sometimes
Reggie Miller had the luxury of his
sister being the greatest female
basketball player there you just get
better
you just get you get better exactly
advanced do you feel like you were
affected by that I do because well so my
dad raised my brother raced they raced
together so then I was always kind of
the one in the grandstands not old
enough to be in the pit so I'm video
recording the whole race and going over
and and filming it so then we take it
home and we watch it and we dissect it
we go through it so I'm listening and
learning and watching and taking all of
that in at a younger age at edge you
know and then when it's my turn to do it
I've already got that knowledge ahead of
time I'm ahead of the game 100% so if
people would argue say that I'm better
look hurt so how how how is how is how
much is the physical like in you know
it's so clearly a big time mental sport
how much is physical I don't know I'm
actually just genuinely that's it's so
physical for sure I mean like oh so
because like unless you're under caution
but like the whole time you're driving
you're tensed as [ __ ] right like you're
like holding on to the wheel you're like
making small
movements sometimes quick movements a
lot of [ __ ] in there it's absolutely hi
yeah that's getting hotter - how much -
how much weight do you lose after I've
seen guys from 7 to 11 pounds lose
weight that's awesome water weight
during the race like some I don't eat as
well as I like for a month I'm I just
poke it just go for a run and don't stop
until you lose seven well he says 160
because a thermometer shut off at 150
9.9 that's nuts man
yeah it was hot it was like do people
get like is there like a worry about it
getting too hot people do fainting and
[ __ ] it happens yeah sure guys gotta get
out yeah of course nobody got out in
that race but yeah like lower divisions
lower I think we're all accustomed to it
we've all been around it I'm gonna hit
though so I'll get amazing the pit crew
guys that certainly come a long ways
right it used to be these guys that
worked on your car now they don't even
work on the car they're strictly
athletes they are only solely therefore
pitting like us thus it and a specific
thing yeah like right yeah like I feel
like I'm the left tire [ __ ]
or is it all for tits front versus rear
but I'm a rear tire dude like yeah I may
be like at an airport stuck and delayed
see some dude me like hey what do you do
he's like I'm a rear tire changer for
this car number 18 that's right that's
cool yeah we fly private but yeah
respect you guys you're a big team not
everybody in the league what happens
when you win yeah so how you know and
actually you want you we want to get
into a question this is so fun though
hold on before because I'm actually I
need to do more of these kind of ears
where I'm like dangerously knowledgeable
but not really it's kind of like more
fun for me Google did you google me or
did you just know I flat I didn't do
anything I fly don't know who you are
okay I but you're right like like as
soon as you said your brother's name
like right I've heard like that clicked
but like I what was super interesting
for me is my whole life I've wanted to
buy the New York Jets and deep down how
close are you it's interesting I'm I'm
not that close and then i but i'm doing
things that make me feel close to this
whole company is being built to buy like
sprite and then flip it or Emma so I
feel like I'm like I'm pouring all my
money back into this machine
so it doesn't look in my bank account
like I'm that close right yeah but I'm
but I've got quit but I've got the
equity that can convert very quickly in
a clear window that's good um I always
thought that one of the weird ways I was
gonna buy the Jets was to do something
in an emerging sport ride the wave of
the equity growth and flip it mm-hmm
so like the inside joke with my family
that a lot of them know was I always
joke that I would buy the Milwaukee
Bucks and I was super right like NBA
teams have exploded in value in the last
decade and that would have been the
right bet Soccer MLS when Steve Ross who
owns the Dolphins bought a piece of
vaynermedia yep and he owns this whole
twenty billion dollar Hudson Yards thing
within the negotiation I negotiated with
him with the rights to be his partner to
own the Miami MLS team it was done it
was awesome and then Beckham retired and
in his claws what he came from Europe
was he could get a team given to him in
any market and he picked Miami so that
[ __ ] me up and then you hate him for
that an enormous amount and and and then
finally I always thought about NASCAR
and what was interesting to me was the
way you wanna buy a team look I got one
but your team is probably super
expensive my Truck Series team you can
buy that Oh your truck series team I
know you're trying to I understand that
that's different what what I'm
interested in with NASCAR actually is
that I always felt that app marketing
was my arbitrage and I thought I could
buy a junior team or start one and
disproportion revenue from brands worth
get a lot more money and then I deserved
based on the drivers I had at first so
I've always had you know I also when a
dollar stores first came to America yeah
this was in the early 90s they actually
had real stuff not the stuff they now
make for the dollar store and one of the
best flips I ever had was I bought a ton
of NASCAR figures the reason I really
know Bill Elliott like really is because
I would buy Bill Elliott figures at the
dollar store those were probably the
easiest ones to get cuz they were what
all over him
white white yeah huh that's how I
remember it but I could be wrong
blue this is it possible that he was not
sponsored by McDonald's his whole career
like before yeah but I don't know that
that teenager lines out have been Coors
yeah pull a bill Elliot action figure
watch this this is my [ __ ] fun this
is getting like I got quiet cuz I'm like
now like focused anyway I'll tell the
story during during those action-figure
days yeah these are all the new ones red
right knock this [ __ ] I'm going yeah
this is all new [ __ ] this is like I'm
gonna look up retro yeah I'm gonna go
1980 not 1988 they didn't have those
back then brother I'm telling you right
now I don't I'm um they look like
bush-league starting lineups you're
gonna [ __ ] when I show you when I find
one nascar figures we're stalling I
don't care because it's super worth it
while I'm stalling um I'm so [ __ ]
obsessed now to find this [ __ ] that one
nope that's a bobblehead bro it's not an
action figure um it's not a bobble head
so you have bobble heads back then
either yes dude bobble heads are from
the 60s they read [ __ ] not NASCAR
ones you Millennials all right so I'm
not dude you are you should yes you are
you're no you're an older millennial I'm
not lazy and don't work don't brand them
that way I'm a big fan of Millennials I
think people [ __ ] on them but a lot of
them weren't it I good I know you did um
okay I'll find him
well we'll edit it into here when we
find I don't want to stall back to your
point I appreciate you enjoying speed as
well what is talk to me about how you
think about so you are one of the
dominant racers in the sport so you have
endorsement deals and other business
ventures outside the track how are you
seeing the social media thing you know
when I think about you and I think about
ælis actors and other people that are at
the top of their sports they tend to
look down on social because they're
making bigger economics making a
commercial doing appearance fees but
recognizing that is potentially your
filter how do you see it overall because
I see it as the way we build up the long
tail of a bunch of the kids that are
emerging that maybe aren't on the
biggest teams they may be funny or
good-looking it might not be just what
they do on the
Act what is you know what you know I
know enough about you as well from an
entrepreneurial kind of like you're not
a schlemiel back to the comment you made
about the millennials thing I have a
feeling your post racing career could be
as grand as your racing career one of
the reasons I was excited to have you
here so I know a little more than I lead
on - how do you think about the social
media thing the digital age all of this
stuff you went into such a huge circle
that oh there's so many different ways I
can answer that - I might not do be on
track but so in the beginning let's
start with yes I fortunately have made
it in a perfect enough time that I still
have a decent sized contract where I can
make pretty good money but there's still
also the PSAs and the other things that
are on the side that you still have the
social presence everybody is all about
social right now and they're all talking
about how to continue to not only market
ourselves and how we can add value to
our sponsors but then how our sponsors
will utilize that social and that social
presence the amount of followers and
everything that we have to continue to a
elevate their brand and everything that
they've had for me it's a great mix and
with my partners it I couldn't think of
a better mix that I could have with Mars
which is M&Ms kettle Snickers and those
folks because we're actually doing a
throwback scheme for the Darlington race
which now is like all about obviously
throw backs but it depends on the era in
which different drivers choose to do
their throw backs from and mine is
skittles it's a skittles race this year
so we're doing an Ernie Irvan 1998
throwback scheme well skittles did a
whole video presentation we filmed it
and produced it at Joe Gibbs Racing and
helped our sponsor and launch it through
that through digital presence no
commercial no going to ESPN no herewhere
or whatever sorry to cut you off
Racing champions well that's Richard
Petty I know that I have to find the
Billy Elliot one okay that's what they
look like
I follow now got it okay so anyway they
did exist they were small you know
amazing this is even better for me than
I found this one because it has the one
I found on the Internet has the Kmart
sticker on it for 48 I used to go to the
dollar store at the Phillipsburg mall
buy them for a dollar then walk across
the mall and return them to Kmart for
for 48 without a receipt
no receipt and they gave me cash I did
this to the tune of about making four to
eight thousand dollars until finally
like a year and a half into this racket
they were like hey we now have a new
policy you need to have a receipt yeah
which you started the whole receipt yeah
I think I did that at least in filtered
mall Kmart and then what I did was I
bought one for 448 and kind of
manipulated that receipt to be able to
use it to continue it so I was unfazed
by the receipt scandal of 1991 so it's
probably illegal but when you're 14 like
you don't know yeah and it's not illegal
when you're 14 right that's okay that's
on the record all right talk to me about
the thing you're most excited about in
sport and we're gonna go to our first
question
I think what's really really cool about
today in our sport is it starting to
mimic a lot of what was going on in the
70s where you had these really big
powerful three four or five guys in the
sport that would win all the races but
then there was some more of the other
drivers that they're not less drivers
they're not wanted but the next year
right and when would they be able to
come in and either a steel wins or be
beat these top three it's the top three
the big three right now in our sport but
when would they be able to be those guys
no three as racing driver
Jimmy so myself Kevin Harvick and Martin
Truex Jr have won 16 of the last 21
races holy [ __ ]
one more time 16 of the last 22 dudes
because I would have a BBQ notice how I
said Jimmy cuz I still thought you know
cuz I'm not being as close attention you
Kevin Harvick who's a big deal who I'm
aware didn't third guy I haven't heard
of you Martin Truex Jr Martin what
Martin Truex Jr his last name's Truex is
a Jersey guy his last name's Truex yes
and he's a Jersey guy nice from Jersey
he's my favorite racer I would imagine
so yeah
his last thing is Truex yes that's
[ __ ] amazing like you could do so much
marketing with that okay and you hate
him right
no I like him as a guy but you want to
bash his [ __ ] face on the racetrack
yes okay I'll admit that thank you
is actually kind of my teammate but oh
that right that whole weird dynamic that
which I like but the other got but the
other guy's not your team II know huh
he's he black and yellow the other guy
he's uh what is he think about you yeah
he's Bush Bush beer god he's my last
name white and red right red okay or
white and black got it Jimmy John's
white and black
what's going on with Jimmy he just he
had a great career he's he's having a
bad year
unfortunately the Hendrick guys have
kind of tailed off a little bit so right
yeah the Hendrick group the whole group
there he's not having a Gavin one in
over 365 days [ __ ] that's like the first
time ever they're freaking out over - oh
yeah already blaming like the what are
they who t blame they're not blaming
anybody complaining somebody working
hard man they're trying to turn it
around bring themselves the weight
that's winner talk but they're blaming
with somebody like the [ __ ] car
manufacturer something something Chris
why are you calling me Chris Chris Chris
you're on with Karen Kyle how are you
guys heard the man hey thanks I
appreciate that what am i me bro
no beers if you're the mentor the Guru I
will his guru corrupted my 13 year old
into watching you back in the Monster
Energy days and also when you were
running the 54 on the truck oh that's a
nice love it real fans which would
question my friend I am a very big car
enthusiast let alone this I guess we
call it a NASCAR superfan hey but more
importantly I am starting a podcast with
Rodney Allen Rippy from jack-in-the-box
Fame and he is a huge car fan okay he
have gone out and done the social media
test marketing we'll call it with a
nostalgia that you're so big in yes and
it's gone very very well when is his
face his name anything to do with the
past in the history we do very well and
if it's a new current face we put him
within just about anything but you know
we got one great shot of launching this
we're gonna do it in SEMA 2018 this year
you're already over the word let me give
you some a very good piece of advice do
not
do not put that fake pressure on
yourself that you have one chance to
launch this thing it's the biggest
mistake that people make with media
properties and businesses they think
there's just especially if you haven't
done it before or it just it's it's
natural human nature right you want to
come out the way it's probably no
different than starting Daytona off on
the right foot like everything like when
I want to win right away you ain't gonna
win right away he's gotta build into it
I I really don't want here's why I'm
most worried about it my friend I don't
want you to do behaviors that so
overvalue the short term in something
where you're playing for life you're
trying to build something that you hope
pays for your livelihood around some up
around a passion you have I assume right
the idea is you'd love for this to be
whether it's a podcast or a media
property this is what you do for the
rest of your life making the kind of
money that lets you live the lifestyle
you want
is that correct it's one of a few
components I I am definitely on your you
know willing to eat [ __ ] as long as it
takes load good so then so then I would
say everything sounds great
don't over worry about the launch
because it may be episode 96 that really
turns the tide does that make sense okay
yeah the luxury you have is that you
don't work for a television network like
ESPN didn't buy the rights to you and
then the ratings were bad after three
and they canceled it you have full
control of content and distribution you
don't have to worry about popping
because you're not at the mercy of
Nielsen ratings and advertisers and all
the other dynamics that traditional
media had to worry about if you had a
radio show you know 20 years ago around
this subject matter if your first six
weeks didn't go well your finish I mean
here in New York mic Francesa was the
legendary sports guy he left retired
they put in a show at last like three
five weeks and Francesa was back because
the ratings weren't there you don't have
that so don't I think before you even
asked a question to make the launch pop
make sure that you realize you don't
need the launch to pop you'd be nice for
it to be great but don't over worry
about that perfect now I really
appreciate that is you know it's it's to
the point where I've got some good
guests lined up and things and we're
going out is a really good time it's
just a matter of I didn't want to leave
though
for other things on the table partly
because I didn't know what these next
four things should be so that helped out
very well good yeah let it come to you I
think you know Kyle just just for fun
here just cuz I love sports and like
strategy and the story I promise you in
19 years when I run into you on
something I'm gonna recall this because
I don't forget things that hit me the
fact that you recorded those races it
was over before it started
you were so mentally like knowledgeable
yeah it's what it's you know it's how I
think about everything you know that
must have been that's such a remarkable
advantage that you had I would presume
that that's why I could be as good as I
am today but I would say that it's also
due to a lot of hard work over the
course no question there was a basis
there was a start so just just knowing
how the chess moves played out and so so
let me ask you a question based on that
and this is gonna help Chris here a
little bit
do you I'm very curious about how you
handle a bad start to a race and just
like to me that the psychology of
everything is so interesting I just know
for a fact without knowing any of the
racers that there's a certain percentage
of guys who if it doesn't start right
are just in a bad place
yeah I would agree absolutely I've had
those moments I would admit that when
something bad starts and it doesn't
quite go right that it's like ah it's
over before it started or whatever you
start cussing on the radio and throwing
everything all all over the place in the
road right right throwing people under
the bus whatever it might be but you
know sometimes you can work your way
back out of those what is the greatest
work your way out of race of your career
oh man like just really go there with me
right now because I think it's
interesting do you remember a race or
maybe like just yeah like the first ten
laps or [ __ ] I don't know like all four
tires fell off the car in the first lap
and then you want it like do if you like
really thought I'm buying you some time
here to think really thought about like
what's the race that I want in my career
on the big stage that that honestly in
the series not earlier than that that I
did not think I was like the one that I
most that I one that I most did not
think I was going to win there's plenty
of those out there but that hasn't say
that it was a race at Watkins Glen years
ago or
the first few pace laps like you're
scrubbing your tires back and forth
you're speeding up slowing down trying
to warm your brakes up and stuff okay
and you feel that the lead and within
the frame rails of the car to make the
car make weight to go over scales is
loose like nobody put the spacers in
there that hold the lead tight against
the bolts so it's sliding forward when
you're on the brakes and it's going
backwards when you're on the gas so it
keeps moving and it's a big slam like
this is 80 pounds sliding around in the
frame rail of the car I have no idea
what he's saying so it sounds so [ __ ]
smug he's gonna so we had to come down
pit road before the race started and
actually take the frame the bolt out of
the frame rail put the spacers in there
to space it back where it needed to be
put the bolt back in and had to start in
the back and I came back through and I
don't recall if I won that one but I
know that no I finished top five but I
don't remember if I finished first
started telling the story you thought
you wanted as you were telling you're
like [ __ ] wait a minute I thought these
internet dudes are like in there like
[ __ ] you dude you came in third 13
seconds off the pace which one well yeah
what he broke his foot and won the race
and won the race hey no no no no no okay
no it's different than that yeah tell me
what it was tell me what it is tell me
what it is get in here Chris get in here
what was it it was a Daytona had a bad
crash without a good portion of the
season I'm the first place he came Bobby
some of the most some of the most
determinated person there is in racing
we came back in the point pointed his
way into the championship and won it I
also won races by the way to get my way
back in I get that but yeah yeah well so
what'd you think
does your son like obsess over Kyle yes
more so in trucks and Bush because
they're shorter races and he doesn't
have the attention span but that's why
he started back when Charlie was still
run into 54 yeah yeah those were the
truck I understand I think if Kyle's got
ninety to win in in the secondary series
of what I'll call the Busch Series okay
and we went so often that we watch Scott
win every weekend when we were there
live let's actually talk about this so
you're telling me your son is a front
runner
and jumps on bandwagons no he started in
diapers at 2 years old watching Kyle I
love it that's that means you made him
watch Kyle cuz I don't know any
two-year-old that's like oh there's Kyle
I'm gonna be a fan he you know we love
hot wheel and it feels were live and
they were raised battle Chris I respect
where you come from listen and oh not
something to do with it probably let me
give you a piece of advice it sounds
like you're also doing some content with
new faces when you do that
run Instagram and Facebook ads to the
tune of a hundred to a thousand dollars
a piece around people that are fans of
those things okay
like for example I'll take this
askgaryvee show and we will run this
episode on Facebook and Instagram
against fans we're doing it with the
live right now we're running ads against
this live right now against what so so
it's really a what's amazing about the
new world is Kyle's getting a new
exposure to my world and all the
entrepreneurs that are watching and and
honestly I think what's most interesting
to me is entrepreneurs tend to be very
creative and get caught into
storytelling I I'm just fascinated how
many people are gonna actually now watch
or become fans off of this that's how it
all works and vice first so you'll be
able to do that with the people that you
put the new faces on with him so make
sure you do that as well okay absolutely
yeah no I'll tell ya I'm not a bandwagon
guy oh my no no I was making a joke
friend my dad was it yeah my dad was the
senior fan my mom was a DW fan so for
the NASCAR people they'll know that yep
nice I was an ally quickie fan and
unfortunately he passed away as champion
in a in a crash at Bristol and I
followed this guy called Jeff Gordon so
I've been around there forever heard
there I respect that buddy I'm there you
know take care right oh man thanks that
was probably the best call you've ever
picked you've been you've been cold
you're kind of like you're like Jimmy
and the Hendrix team you're cold right
now and so you need to like pick it up
sweat it this guy's last name is Truex
yeah yeah I'm very excited about this
and what do you you don't know what part
of jerseys from do you alpharetta right
yeah Mae Etta Mae Etta Mae Etta New
Jersey
alpharetta that's Georgia yeah it is
George I was like why do I know that my
friend moose lives in Alpharetta Georgia
by the way Atlanta traffic sucks [ __ ] so
does Charlotte man hi 77 is Tara hate it
oh gosh yeah
the Broncos Raiders think huh I'm
telling you that's gonna become a big
deal hey I don't know man you love Bryce
Harper cuz he's from Vegas from Vegas
yeah yeah like that yeah he's good dude
he's a really good dude
yeah I'm fascinated by that guy I think
he's I think the baseball system has
suppressed how much of a superstar he is
as a person and a fast things like one
of the only baseball players that I even
know of today did you catch that whole
controversy worth like the Commissioner
of baseball kind of threw Mike Trout one
of the best if not the best player kind
of under the bust or any all-star
weekend saying it's up to him to build
his personal brand to add Missa
it's very interesting cuz I do think
baseball and ask are actually very
ironically are in very similar spots in
different ways where there's so much
gold and it just needs to be mined a
little different a little more
contextual a little more storytelling
like like to me you and this dude that
blocked you for 12 [ __ ] laps yeah you
guys need to go into a steel cage
armwrestling live on Facebook what kind
of did in Week three you want how many
space I didn't throw no helmet I threw
yeah have you guys were you guys now
these I once punched my brother AJ on a
basketball court and I've never really
said it because I don't want to admit it
actually happened but it actually you
were they all ready for that one you
were there for that one or I think it
was before when you guys played bottom
line I understand the difference between
the heat of the battle in real life like
I died for my brother AJ and I've done
like remarkable things that I feel very
proud of for my brother but I really you
know kind of weirdly punched him for a
boxing out situation that I thought was
inappropriate so are you cool this guy
was still lingering and there's a real
heated controversy still brewing he
tried to like put a kibosh to it cuz he
I respect that
didn't really want any more lingering if
after he boxed me out which he should
have because there's that's just right
let me ask you a question cuz I want to
learn I want to learn the sport through
your experiences so let's say you guys
didn't have that little beef in week 3
yeah would it have been like
the unwritten rule for him to let you
have that chance to try to win it if you
guys were teammates so if he wasn't
yes so he first and foremost should go
out there and try to win the race if
he's go out there and try to win the
race and he's gonna be catching that guy
that's in front of him more power to him
to stay in front of respect when he's
falling back and that guy out front is
getting farther away and I'm up his ass
trying to pass him and he's finally
asking me yes that's like that's bad and
that was that bad not bad I mean I can
do whatever he wants but he should
pisses me off I'm telling you I really
this is this final race thing let's
let's make it a real vaynermedia thing
let's just like let's get really into
the final race of the year when is it
Homestead November 18th ish on a Sunday
oh yeah that's a problem
see the Jets are playing now what time I
don't know probably just want you to sin
I got married in November and went on my
honeymoon in February in case the Jets
made the playoffs both of my children
would you ever do that stop it my both
don't make me become a fan of the number
to a guy who blocked you for 12 Brad's
um I I also have two children born in
summer months and literally not like by
accident like my life revolves around
did you have IVF babies or no no but we
like the strategizes Pratt you practice
during that time of year we like focused
on that time here more than practice
that was like try to achieve non baby
life during football season because I
would pick the Jets over my children's
birthday parties okay
that's firm so your [ __ ] homestead is
the easy one for me now what time is
homestead probably three o'clock cuz
they could well you know what is that
that what a week I might come do we do
this for sure it's gotta it's around I
don't know if that's the day is that the
day
give me the Sunday November 18th three
o'clock start the Jets are on a bye this
is a [ __ ] sign I'm gonna go crazy at
Homestead where is it exactly nowhere is
it exactly in Miami it is not in Miami
it's in Homestead Florida it's Miami
Homestead Florida yeah it's like an hour
from Miami
we all went what's this we all they all
together general bye you two go to the
race last year when you got blocked yeah
when he was getting blocked did you
understand what the [ __ ] was going on
Hannah yeah yeah I'm nobody like this I
know she didn't I know she did it uh all
right so clearly breaking news there's a
significant chance I'm gonna be in
Homestead
my wife's watching this right now me
like this [ __ ] guy the only by week
when our family actually can have a
normal to gether now he has to go to
[ __ ] homestead anyway all right let's
get one more question and this is too
fun are you good at social media or do
you let a team take care of it like do
you personally go in there when I do it
what do you like to do Twitter or
Instagram what are you I don't even know
how to post on Instagram Jesus Christ I
have a guy who's behind you get it like
I go on - you know what that was to me
that's like me saying to you like I
don't know how to drive a car what you
just said just so you know um you live
in New York do you know how to drive a
car of course I grew up in Jersey I
really know how to drive a car yeah one
that has scratches and dents
ridiculously you know what what do you
drive I Drive a Land Rover okay like not
a car that like like I've never driven
like try to think of if I've had
anything sporty I had you know Lincoln
once made a sports car for like four
minutes it was the craziest thing out of
nowhere from like the big [ __ ] huge
town car in like the late 90s which was
fast I loved it but yeah I know I didn't
grow up like car oriented or racing what
I what I'm crazy though about the way I
drive is actually completely wild what
if people are not gonna answer your call
because they don't know if phone number
is calling then we say [ __ ] you and they
[ __ ] missed it okay so there's the
other phone like yeah leave a message I
don't know who this is because I think I
think that you're an all-time great
racer and I still think at the end of a
Jets game to get back to my apartment I
think I can beat you because I am
completely and utterly out of control
vieni like after a race no I'm okay
after a Jets game beat you back to your
apartment yeah because it's not racing
understanding traffic and being willing
to break out you have any advantages
right well I'm trying to win this anyway
I laid when I Drive on curbs I let go
like I just like I'm really into the
time ya see TV I was gonna say we can
make a TV show about that or a pod not a
podcast but a vlog about that but it's
the law so like let's just do edit
ticket and then like be renegades what
so I did this I did this one thing one
time there was a radio show host out of
Washington DC and they would bring in
celebrities and stuff and they would do
like a Beltway race okay so like you
start at one point you start at the
radio station you get on the Beltway you
go around the Beltway for a lap you come
back to the radio station right so all
the cops are like standing on overpasses
and they're looking and and whatever
whatever so they're talking like we're
live on phone on the car phone it's
amazing back to the radio station so
they're asking us like okay well were
you at so I'm leading and I'm like a
half a mile to almost three-quarters of
a mile ahead of the other one behind me
right because I'm getting through
traffic pretty good and stuff so a cop
pulls me over and puts me on the side of
the road and I'm like yeah what did I do
like you know you didn't do anything I'm
just letting the other guy catch up and
I'm like this is freaking me like really
so then as soon as the other guy passes
me he lets me go and you still won well
no so then the reason why this all ended
is because we we started racing like on
the street racing like door-to-door and
like getting back to the radio station
so he turns into the radio traffic's
coming and he turns into the radio
station and I turn in underneath him and
I just door slam him like kartik are
just door slam him and I beat him back
to the to the door you know I gotta tell
you so they were like we can't do this
anymore like that's that's like too many
liabilities and things like that I was
like I didn't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna door
the guy I'm very into you you're now my
favorite racer like I would do that that
was so like I can do that though to me
Ivan Drago said it best if he dies he
dies I'm listen that's just the way to
like to live life that's just a good way
to live life are you getting a call he's
trying who's this
Amy wonder if I know this Amy wowyou
dorsum that's exactly right
do you do that big door slam guys listen
when I compete I'm literally willing to
do anything
it's a chemicals change in my body hi hi
is this Amy hi no I'm not Amy are you
Amy
or is your mom Amy Amy can you get hurt
yeah thank you
mom's be with you you're a buret hey
brother how are you hey how old are you
Helen amazing are you watching the
askgaryvee show with Kyle Busch right
now okay fantastic do you have a
question yeah what is it how do you get
into racing all right good question I
mean it's not very simple it's not like
going and being in little league
baseball and picking up a bat and a
glove and a ball and going and playing
at your local field right so getting
into racing is getting a go-kart like
you it's expensive like you have to go
out and buy the things to be able to go
out here and do that so racing at the
local level is where I started I started
in go-karts first messed around with
those for a little bit and then got into
legends cars they're more expend more
expensive but the reason why I kept
moving up and getting into those things
was because I kept winning and what I
was racing Shane do you when you start
winning at such a youth level do
sponsors start coming in and subsidizing
families not yes and no yeah not at my
level so he started in go-karts are you
in go-karts yeah you are
well not anything em but I have a go
humble guys all right wheeler well there
you go
heck yeah are you gonna be a NASCAR
driver one day yeah I really hope I and
all kinds of things
I just want to great you just want a
race look that's all I wanted to do what
you're the metal one I'm sorry that's
exactly right and why do you want to
race I don't know just go into it and is
it because you like the wind well
watching it to panic and bam racing
started oh yeah you like beating other
people and rate when you race do you
love destroying the other kid well I'm
meeting my dad I'm beautiful really
beautiful really
what's on Bionic Everett do you do you
think your dad's letting you win because
you're such a little kid or are you
destroying your dad's face he let me win
but I don't want it you don't want that
oh you should stop that what is your
last name Everett because it's very
important because one day when you're
winning championships I'm gonna clip
this air it and get millions of viral
views well last name is writin Wilson
erasing very good I didn't catch it
Everett listen thank you so much for
calling awesome an aberrant hey welcome
Everett you go out there and you kick
your dad's butt and tell him that you're
the best all right okay Everett before
you go tell Kyle to stay in racing long
enough so when you get there you destroy
his face okay give me ten years buddy is
that what do you think what's that talk
to me about you know one thing I've been
fascinated by in professional sports is
when I was growing up it was unheard of
for guys to play at the highest level at
37 39 41 you know conditioning look
underlining performance-enhancing drugs
there's a lot of things that may be
contributing to this evolution of 365
cycles guys not just Hagan you know
you guys are on all the time but like
drinking beer
don't you offseason you know like how
much longer do you think you can race
and do you feel like it is a young man's
sport
or is there a fall-off at a certain
point I hope that there you go Tim
Knight he's awesome that's perfect
that's amazing I hope that I get to go
another 13 15 years I mean I don't know
there was guys who was the oldest and
most competitive rich richer petty
seemed to be richer hey Richard fell off
his last eight years okay so who did you
say was the mark Martin's one at 53 Wow
yeah that's awesome it rare yeah he
wanted me yeah we want a warning that
was what it was a Winston Cup he know
he'll he raced in the Sprint Cup yeah
all right then I was in 11 was his last
year what do you think you think you
think you've got 33 I'm thinking like
mid-40s I'm probably about done see and
how do you like those guys though they
started older so they started at 35 33
35 so that right they started racing Cup
yeah because because it just took them
longer to get there and because nowadays
everybody gets there sooner like kids
they start sooner 18 20 22 whatever
they're starting sooner so then the
sponsors can stick with them for longer
right understand so back then it wasn't
that way we're now so I started my first
year in Cup I was 18 years old so if I
was 18 when I started those guys were 33
they retired at 53 it's kids in the game
now right he is chase yeah chase saw
how's his career starting off um chases
he's good he's talented he does a really
nice job he's very polished and talks
well but he hasn't won yet right until
you win you got you got a break yeah
he's been close actually his closest
thing he was I stole the win from him so
you feel good about that I don't feel
good what are you talking about you
should feel tremendous about that it was
a badass finish I mean I must say there
was 40 laps to go and I was four seconds
back the old school establishment that
loved his dad super pissed at you oh
absolutely it was totally yeah [ __ ]
blowing me up like screw him he's an ass
like you shoulda let chase when and I'm
like should've let him he's what
I'll [ __ ] punch Evert the
eight-year-old
his face to beat him in any game we play
tomorrow there is no should let win
right exactly no more there's no ribbons
there's no true there's no participation
trophies cuz you're like [ __ ] you crowd
I do a bow yeah
like see I'm from Vegas the showmanship
like every show in Vegas ends with a bow
yeah right so that was me yeah oh that's
another one so the other one is like a
crybaby just a little longer I'm
actually gonna become a like are you
genuinely and like so good outside of
everybody who's a fan of you basically
hates you'll and I feel like John Cena
Lance oh yeah oh yeah dude yeah dude
this is trying to get good problem for
me is when I get into something new I
have to go with somebody who's not
winning cuz it's to front-running I love
that you're a dick well you've got
plenty to choose from so chases chases
emerging what about the up what about
the gentleman I saw a profile on
SportsCenter one early morning with
because of my son now I'm watching
SportsCenter again the Japanese American
dude right Kyle Larson yeah talk to me
about him he's good he's won he's won
before he's won he won well so we go to
Michigan next week right that's like his
track he's won there let he won there
like three times in a row really yeah I
think I don't know where he finished in
the spring race there this year but he's
always faster so he's having a solid
nice young career so uh so this year he
hasn't won a race this year right he has
accelerating the way that yes so last
year last year I think he won four races
a year before that he won two or three
and this year they're they're all kind
of yeah
there's a lot of guys on a dry spell I
mean 16 of 21 races have been won by the
big three so and how this big three
feels fairly new though to me like like
are the other two got like so the other
guy heard of the Truex guy I haven't so
like but that's again I'm not how long
has Truex been good two years right so
he's fairly new makes sense yeah what
else made him right I saw the side of
your eye I was so pumped right now you
ought to [ __ ] break his face I love
it Kyle honestly makes me love you so by
the way bro I'm serious again the AJ
thing I'm telling you like I you know
like I'm terrible on the court or like
I'm a bad dude when it comes to
competing because I want to win so bad
and that's what you're supposed to do
well you did the chase is exactly right
and by the way do you know how I think I
think that probably helps chase in the
macro or it doesn't it exposes chase if
he crumbles out of a devastating
last-second loss and then he was never
meant to be great anyway and if he's
meant to be great
he'll [ __ ] go on and [ __ ] domini
and probably reference that race one day
absolutely that's the way you should who
brushed your soul as a rookie
what would the closest when you had
before you had a win that you got hurt
or did you kind of not have that moment
where it was like you kind of never were
that close so my first my first Busch
Series race so the first race I ran in
ever in the Xfinity series okay help me
there I'm back solo convince me mm
that's not the it was 2003 triple-a got
it what I don't know how it goes does it
go triple-double
okay so triple-a Xfinity series which
was the one right before yeah it was
2003 it was my first race ever in that
car I qualified third led a lot of laps
and one of the big dogs from the Cup
Series Matt Kenseth beat me I know that
dude I finished second my first ever
start like that was crushing so then
after that but in that crush there must
have been an under while you're eating
like some cheeseburger pissed there must
have been an underlining like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill all these guys cuz if
they're [ __ ] letting me come in second
in my first [ __ ] race you're in deep
[ __ ] it's the way I think about
vaynermedia in the first year that I
kind of ran this company I took it from
3 to 14 million and I was like and I
just remember thinking and we have
devastating losses where we came in
second I just remember thinking you're
in deep [ __ ] fëanor sports my brother
and I now do football representation
this was kind of like our first official
year and I'm in the living room in the
final two or three for Sam Darnell and
Josh Rosen two top quarterbacks coming
out of the race way into the league we
didn't get either but when we didn't get
them all I thought about was these guys
are in deep [ __ ] in the sports
representation business cuz if you're
letting me in the [ __ ] room for the
[ __ ] number one quarterbacks in year
two and we're still [ __ ] [ __ ]
around and haven't even really started
I'm gonna slice your [ __ ] throats is
that what you thought when you came in
second
race but are you absolutely no question
horse that's how we're ending this
[ __ ] episode punching seven-year-olds
slicing throats [ __ ] I'm into this
I'm getting fired up cop thank you so
much all right being up yeah yes you get
to ask the question of the day so all
the people watching right now this is a
way for you to get like maybe some
debate settled or maybe something you're
curious about what people are thinking
out there you get to ask the question of
the day you can go a night by the way
you can ask people favorite color I
don't care where you go or you could be
very thematic to what we've been
question of the day hmm
all right um what made you become a
NASCAR fan of today love it I can't wait
to see all the answers of this episode
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]